Salut, pour ce jeudi du hors sujet je voulais répondre un peu à la question
ou vous me demandez souvent si un mentaliste arnaque les gens.
écoutez les autres je sais pas. Moi en tout cas non ça me parait évident
mais ça m'a donné envie de vous parler d'un bel arnaqueur
je ne sais pas s'il était mentaliste mais en tout cas il était très malin puisque je vais vous parler d'un homme
qui s'est retrouvé 47 fois en prison pour des faits qui étaient avérés,
qui a toujours été libéré au bout d'un ou deux jours
parce que les victimes ne portaient pas plainte contre lui.
Et sa plus belle arnaque c'était en 1925
puisque Victor Lustig a vendu la tour Eiffel.
Victor est né en 1890 en Autriche/Hongrie
c'était pas une famille aisée-aisée c'était pas une famille non plus dans le besoin donc
il eut toute l'éducation qu'il fallait, il a fait toutes ses études
il a brillamment passé ses diplômes d'avocat
mais Lustig ne voulais pas réussir comme tout le monde
il voulait gagner beaucoup d'argent et très rapidement pour profiter de sa jeunesse.
Vers 19 ans il est venu s'installer à Paris c'était en plein dans la belle époque.
Il a rapidement trouvé un business qui lui convenait, en tout cas qui lui convenait pour l'époque
il est devenu proxénète donc il avait 2 jeunes femmes à son service.
Ça c'est très très mal passé puisqu'il était pas forcément violent
c'était pas... c'était pas un gangsta.
Il s'est prit un gros coup de couteau dans le visage et il a arrêté cette profession.
Et surtout il s'est dit : "Comment je peux gagner beaucoup d'argent...
..d'une manière pas très honnête mais sans risquer d'être inquiété".
Et cette idée là il va la tenir de Nicky Arnstein.
Victor travaillait sur des tournois de poker
quand je dis travailler; c'est qu'il trichait, qu'il récupérait des petites mises
Et Arnstein l'avait repéré.
Il l'a un peu pris sous son aile et lui a donné des conseils, il lui a dit :
"Ce qu'il faut absolument c'est que tu joues contre des personnes et quand elles perdent contre toi
elles se disent c'est de ma faute,...c'est de ma faute j'avais qu'à pas faire ça".
À partir du moment où tu déportes la culpabilité sur la personne que tu pigeonnes;
alors cette personne ne t'en voudras pas, en tout cas pas au point de faire des représailles contre toi.
Et c'était super malin comme mode de réflexion.
Lorsque le bateau de croisière je ne vous avez peut être pas précisé ça
sur lequel il avait rencontré Nicky à accosté aux États Unis,
il est allé à Boston et là il a commencé à appliquer ça.
Il a continué à si monter des arnaques de plus en plus grosses
jusqu'en 1925; où il prend un papier en tête, de la ville de Paris
et il convoque les 5 plus gros ferrailleurs de Paris.
Il les reçois tous les 5 dans un salon privé et il leur explique qu'il est mandaté par le Président de la République
qui était Doumergue à l'époque
pour vendre la tour Eiffel qui n'avait plus tellement d'utilité en fait
et le président souhaite s'en débarrasser mais ça coûte très très cher à démonter
donc il la vend au ferrailleur qui fera la meilleure offre
et ce dernier devra évidemment la démonter.
Il y a une seule condition à tout ça c'est que tout doit rester très discret jusqu'à la signature de la vente.
Ce qui parait tout à fait logique.
Victor les emmène visiter la Tour Eiffel
Et alors là c'est très drôle, l'histoire raconte qu'il avait une petite carte...
barrée, tricolore, bleu blanc rouge
qui avait prévu aucun plan spécifique à ce moment là
il y est allé au culot c'est à dire qu'il a foncé
en coupant toute la file des touristes qui attendaient pour la tour Eiffel
il a foncé au guichet avec la carte tricolore en disant :
"ces personnes là m'accompagnent"
et on l'a tout simplement laissé passer parce qu'il a fait preuve d'autorité
de confiance en soi
personne a vérifié si sa carte était vraie ou pas
mais du coup ça a été un très bon convénisseur pour les 5 personnes qui l'accompagnait
et qui ce sont dit "ok tout est cohérent".
Ils ont fait la visite et une petite semaine après il a commencé à recevoir des propositions d'achat
ou tout du moins il en a tout de suite reçu une. C'est celle de Monsieur Poisson.
Comme quoi parfois il y a des pré-dispositions avec son nom
c'est Monsieur Poisson qui lui a envoyé la 1ère offre d'achat
là Victor a pas pris de risques il lui a tout de suite dit ok.
il lui donne rendez vous dans le salon de particuliers où ils s’étaient vus déjà
à l’hôtel Crillon
et se fait payer en bon de la liberté qui était une monnaie d'échange assez courante à l'époque.
Alors malheureusement on ne sais pas combien il lui a vendu
donc on ne sais pas combien lui a proposé le ferrailleur
tout ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y avait forcément un gros pot de vin à côté
puisqu'à cette époque; je suppose que ça a changé aujourd'hui
mais à cette époque pour ce genre de vente ou de marché il fallait forcément graisser un peu la patte
pour être sur d'avoir l'offre
Et le lendemain Lustig partait de Paris
d'une manière plutôt définitive, enfin à la base définitive
Et Monsieur Poisson c'est bien rendu compte qu'il s'était fait arnaquer
et c'est là où c'est très malin puisqu'il n'a pas porté plainte pour pas qu'on se moque de lui et qu'on le trouve ridicule
d'avoir cru qu'il pouvait acheter la tour Eiffel comme ça
c'est la honte qui l'a empêché de porter plainte
malheureusement  ça n'a pas changé grand chose à sa situation puisque
l'affaire à force est éventée ça s'est su et donc il a été un peu la risée de tout Paris à ce moment là
pour que vous ayez un peu la fin de l'histoire de Lustig il a été effectivement arrêté 47 fois
à chaque fois il a été relâché parce que personne n'osait porter plainte soit parce que la personne ne voulais pas paraître ridicule
soit parce que ça les mettais dans le rôle du méchant ou de quelqu'un d'antipathique
il montait toujours ses plans dans ce sens là pour s'en sortir sauf la 48e fois où il a un petit peu déconné
il a arnaqué un gros commerçant à New York pour un spectacle qu'il a jamais monté
sauf qu'il avait pas appliqué sa méthode, le commerçant n'avait aucune raison de ne pas porter plainte contre lui
et il s'est fait gauler...
Direction Alcatraz où il est décédé en 1947
voilà l'histoire de l'homme qui a vendu la tour Eiffel
j’espère que cette histoire comme cette vidéo vous aura plu
si c'est le cas vous pouvez également continuer à lire sur internet en tapant "Victor Lustig"
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui ont été écrite sur sa vie
Et évidemment quand on est malin il ne faut pas s'amuser à faire ce genre de choses là
et si vous avez appris 2/3 choses dans cette vidéo ou au moins si elle vous a intéressé
vous pouvez sans arnaque me laisser un délicat pouce en l'air
vous pouvez aussi commenter la vidéo parce que je lis tous les commentaires j'aime bien ça donc allez y n’hésitez pas
vous pouvez aussi me mettre des idées de choses que vous voudriez pour les prochains hors sujet
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner a la chaîne également avant de partir parce que le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an
ce qui veut dire que demain c'est la moitié du défi
donc rendez vous demain à 17h ciao !